think both these parties are complete
trash
trying to get clout and it's a
popularity contest they get bribes from
lawyers to pass certain laws it's
disgusting the whole process is
absolutely disgusting and it's it's
destined for uh destruction and you
rolled a 100 on the 100-sided I wish it
was more positive 100 it was definitely
100 in a negative vein but this is part
of why I'm not like I do not support
what Kanye said the way he said stuff
but I support a fresh energy in politics
even if it me it's a risk of stepping
they know where you live now you're in
the White House like that's a risk but I
I can't stand by and watch it fall apart
Jesse looked confused a second we
there's a meme when you roll a 20 in
Dungeons and Dragons it means it's like
a perfect success and when you roll a
one it means a perfect failure so
whenever you know Ian says something
people will rate him in the chat it's
either a one total failure or 20 total
success but he has a 100-sided die over
there so when he said both parties are
trash I said you roll the 100 it's like
it could not be better